the year 2023 marks 20 years since the
invasion of Iraq it's likely we're
talking about the war that marked the
adolescence of all the people between 30
and 40 years old who watch this channel
I'm sure many of you still have in your
mind images that are already part of
history images as famous as this one now
I'm sure many of you also remember the
big demonstrations and protests against
the war and this is an interesting thing
because this war took place at about the
same time as the Afghanistan war however
the military intervention in Afghanistan
got much better press everyone
understood that it was an appropriate
response to the 9 11 attacks in contrast
the Iraq War was highly controversial
for two to three years pop culture was
soaked in the war artists like Madonna
and big Hollywood stars like Tim Robbins
and Kim Basinger spoke out against the
U.S invasion of Iraq no blood for oil
was the slogan of mass anti-war protests
that were held around the world well
curiously enough no one doubts 20 years
on that the war in Afghanistan was a
total failure that has ended with the
Taliban back in power after Iran other
embarrassing evacuation of Western
forces meanwhile about 2 500 U.S troops
remain in Iraq today what's more all
indications are that there is no hurry
for them to leave Iraqi prime minister
supports indefinite U.S troop presence
that means a U.S soldier cannot enter
Afghanistan even if he or she wanted to
while at the same time in Iraq they are
almost welcome well not quite but you
get my point so the question is why did
the Iraq War happen to what extent was
it a failure what is a rock like right
now on visualpolitik today we are going
to answer all these questions but first
let's take a little look at a bit of
History listen up
thank you
[Music]
the bad guy in the movie
there was a time back in the 1990s when
the Soviet Union was already less scary
than the X-Files and the Chinese threat
seemed more like a challenge at an
all-you-can-eat Asian restaurant so for
many years Saddam Hussein was the icon
of evil in South Park he was more evil
than the Devil Himself he was so bad
that in the war that pitted Iraq against
Iran in the 1980s the White House ended
up supporting the ayatollah's regime
perhaps to ensure that no one would win
and both sides would lose
in the mid-1980s the Iran Contra Scandal
broke out President Ronald Reagan's
Administration was secretly selling arms
to Iran a country under a U.S arms
embargo with the money obtained the
White House was financing the contracts
an armed group fighting to overthrow the
Nicaraguan government that had emerged
from the sandista revolution both
operations the sale of arms to Iran and
the financing of the contrasts were
prohibited by the U.S Senate
the fact is that peace between Iraq and
Iran did not come until 1988 and not
surprisingly neither side won the
borders remained in the same place they
had been before the war of course almost
a million people lost their lives along
the way and after eight years of
Destruction the economies of both
countries were also destroyed when the
war ended Kuwait which was a petrol
monarchy allied with Saddam Hussein
began to reclaim the money from Iraq
that it had lent to fight the ayatollahs
we're talking about no less than 14
billion dollars so the relationship
between the two countries began to go
awry to the point that Iraq accused
Kuwait of stealing it's oil through the
use of Advanced Techniques in Border oil
fields it was a baseless accusation but
saddam's regime Was preparing the ground
to invade Kuwait which it did in August
1990 provoking a unanimous rejection by
the International Community
for five months diplomacy tried to get
Saddam Hussein to withdraw his troops
from Kuwait the U.N security Council
passed five resolutions to this effect
finally on 16th of January 1991 an
International Coalition of 34 countries
led by the United States and mandated by
the UN launched a military campaign to
force the invading Army to withdraw from
Kuwait U.N resolution 660 which
supported this operation was unanimously
approved
[Music]
and so began the Gulf War the first in
history to be televised live Operation
Desert Storm lasted six weeks and was a
great success come on it was so Fierce
that the US could have easily overthrown
Saddam Hussein General Norman
schwartzkopf in charge of the military
operation says he asked President Bush
senior for one more week to finish off
Sudan but the White House refused in an
interview for PBS's front line
schwartzkopf gives details of why they
didn't topple Sudan in 1991. check it
out I would have loved to have gone to
Baghdad and grabbed Saddam Hussein but
this was not an emotional decision it
was a strategic decision and
strategically we were smart enough to
win the war and win the peace if Saddam
were to be replaced tomorrow he would
probably be replaced with someone who's
just as bad or worse than he is General
Norman Schwarzkopf possibly the younger
amongst you will be thinking okay it's
clear to me that at the end of the last
century Saddam Hussein was the bad guy
in the movie but what did he do to
become such a villain many of you will
even be wondering hang on Josh if he was
so bad why wasn't he overthrown in 1991
well his story began in the 60s in an
era Rife with coup d'etat in Iraq where
Saddam Hussein's position improved so
much that he went from exile to the vice
presidency of the Republic thanks to his
leadership of the Arab socialist bath
party
Arab socialism was a very popular
ideological Trend in the mid-20th
century it involves a mixture of three
crucial elements socialism with a
centralized state-run economy secularism
as they are against putting religious
leadership above political leadership
and militarism with a prominent role for
the armed forces in the organization of
the state
Arab socialism evolved it began as
pan-arabism with the aim of uniting all
Arabs in a single Homeland since they
considered the existing borders to be
artificial but in the end the clashes
between the barthest leaders of the
various countries led to the emergence
of nationalist branches of the bath thus
Saddam Hussein was able to reject any
interference and in 1979 he formally
became the president of Iraq he ruled
with an iron fist surrounding himself
with an elite who like him were Sunni a
religious minority that barely
constituted one-fifth of the Iraqi
population then Saddam invested the
money generated by the oil industry in
the Army he turned it into the fourth
largest army on the planet which is not
bad for a country that at the time had
only 18 million inhabitants and up until
this point many of you may be thinking
well he just sounds like a regular
textbook dictator okay that's true but
it's not only that Saddam oppressed his
own people it is that he even killed
them with chemical weapons yeah that's
what I said
[Music]
in the 1980s Saddam Hussein committed a
series of massacres against the Kurdish
population of Northern Iraq operation
anfal which resulted in the destruction
of 4500 Villages and the murder of some
180 000 civilians has been described by
several countries as a genocide episodes
such as the massacre of halabja a city
that was bombed with chemical weapons
causing 5 000 deaths in just one night a
part of the darkest history of humanity
now let's not be naive either this is
probably not the reason why the West
reacted so strongly against the invasion
of Kuwait another good reason is in the
dinosaur juice Iraq is a rich country in
the Arab world producing significant
amounts of oil and gas and along with
Kuwait its power would have been
excessive keep in mind that we're
talking about a time when fracking had
not yet arrived Middle East oil was also
essential for the United States however
at the same time and for the same reason
Iraq leaded to continue pumping crude
oil to keep prices stable on
International markets and you know what
this may go a long way toward explaining
why the UF did not want to end saddam's
regime yes he was an abhorrent dictator
but he had the country under control and
needed to sell oil to keep funding the
military so then began the carrot and
stick game if you get too big for your
boots we'll give you a tap and threaten
to invade if you behave we'll leave you
alone because that way Iraq remains
stable however this policy changed in
2003 why well listen up
[Music]
no blood for oil
the 911 attacks shocked the Great
American superpower the United States
had been attacked on home soil by
Al-Qaeda and President Bush had launched
a war on terror this led to the invasion
of Afghanistan where the Taliban regime
was harboring Osama Bin Laden the
al-Qaeda leader managed to slip away
from U.S forces so the White House Began
to look everywhere for enemies who may
be lending him a hand and not
surprisingly Saddam Hussein's track
record didn't help of course time has
shown that the links between Al-Qaeda
and Saddam Hussein were false but the
fact that both hated the United States
was enough for the Bush Administration
the U.S government thus succeeded in
getting the UN Security Council to pass
resolution 1441 a resolution in which
the International Community
urged Iraq to cooperate with the
disarmament inspectors but Washington
wanted more it pressed for an ultimatum
to be given to Saddam Hussein however
visualpolitik viewers this ultimatum
timed out and in March 2003 the White
House decided to go to war on its own up
until the very last moment Bush tried to
convince the world of the danger of
inaction intelligence gathered by this
and other governments
leaves No Doubt
that the Iraq regime continues to
possess and conceal some of the most
lethal weapons ever devised indeed the
official reason for invading Iraq was
that Saddam Hussein was hiding the
infamous weapons of mass destruction
[Music]
there were doubts and a significant part
of the International Community opposed
the intervention but despite this in
October 2002 U.S Congress authorized to
attack Iraq if diplomacy failed in fact
President Bush had broad support from
democratic party Senators such as for
example Joseph Biden the current
president of the United States this is
not a blank check for the use of forest
against Iraq for any reason it is an
authorization for the use of force if
necessary to compel Iraq to disarm as it
promised after the Gulf War however
unlike the Gulf War this time there was
no large International Coalition to
fight Saddam Hussein only the United
Kingdom sent a strong contingent of
troops while European governments were
divided between those against the war
such as France and Germany and those
supporting the intervention such as
Spain Italy and much of Eastern Europe
the fact is that perhaps because of this
division The Invasion caused Great
controversy and there were massive
protests all over the world nobody
understood why Iraq had to be in traded
and artists and intellectuals led
International popular movements such as
no to war or no blood for oil but in
spite of everything the invasion was a
great military success
the U.S army conquered Baghdad in just
three weeks and just six weeks after the
War Began President Bush announced the
end of major military operations in Iraq
he did so under a large sign that read
mission accomplished something that was
highly criticized with the passage of
time in view of the fact that the
country was still far from being
pacified in addition in this speech Bush
set a new goal to achieve a democratic
Iraq the transition from dictatorship to
democracy will take time
but it is worth every effort our
Coalition will stay
until our work is done and then we will
leave
and we will leave behind a free Iraq
Baghdad had been conquered and the great
statue of Saddam Hussein had been
toppled the Iraqi Army had been crushed
however there were still many Loose Ends
the most important one was that the
dictator had not yet been captured his
Palace had been taken but there was no
trace of him his money or his alleged
weapons of mass destruction it took half
a year before Saddam was finally found
hiding in a hole in the ground he was
handed over to the new Iraqi authorities
and the trial against him was ended in
the only possible way he was sentenced
to death by hanging and here it's
important to know that Saddam Hussein
was defiant to the end this is how he
reacted to his sentence
in theory the Iraq War was a great
success for the United States it had
reaffirmed its power as the great
military superpower of the moment and
they had every reason to be satisfied
but of course this was only the first
step in the goal of making Iraq
Democratic now comes the big dilemma can
you really build a state from the
outside let's take a look
[Music]
possible to impose democracy
many people think that Bush was deluded
because he thought he could impose
democracy on a country by military means
the idea seemed to be that since Saddam
Hussein had subjected Iraq to a criminal
dictatorship the White House must have
imagined that everyone in Iraq was just
waiting for the Marines to arrive save
them from the Tyrant and then everyone
would live happily ever after the
problem is that the next day you have to
start building a state that among other
things is completely destroyed but let's
say one thing clearly this idea of
coming into a devastated country and
setting up a democracy is something that
had already worked in Germany and Japan
even in South Korea Germany and Japanese
democracy came out of World War II
several years later the United States
was instrumental in making that happen
and out of the Korean war came South
Korea it is true that during the first
decades it went through an authoritarian
system and a military dictatorship but
with U.S support it eventually became a
thriving democracy however back to Iraq
and Afghanistan everything seems more
complicated
thank you
in 2021 the United States ended the
Afghan war and you all saw the disaster
that was Afghan democracy succumbed to
the Taliban in Iraq things have been
different Obama announced the total
withdrawal of U.S troops in 2011 but the
enemies of the young Iraqi democracy
were so strong that they demanded the
return of Uncle Sam just three years
later U.S deploying new Force to Iraq to
boost fate against Islamic State the
United States made many mistakes in Iraq
it bet on leaders who promoted sectarian
and ethnic divisions as a way to win
support politicians who governed for
their own rather than the national
interest and so it was very difficult to
build a new state for all Iraqis another
mistake was to disband the Army this
decision encouraged saddam's former
troops to nurture a budding Insurgency
in multiple armed groups determined to
fight against the Invader an Insurgency
as difficult to fight as it was to
defeat however the reality is that there
have been significant changes in Iraq
free elections have been held since 2005
and within the weakness of the young
Iraqi institutions it could be said that
20 years after Saddam Hussein there is a
functioning democracy in Iraq where
power is transferred relatively
peacefully and there is increasing
Security in the streets even oil
production gives us a good indication as
to how in Iraq that is currently opec's
second largest producer with more than 4
million barrels per day has been
evolving now we're not going to say that
everything is going great in Iraq and
that Baghdad has turned into Las Vegas
one problem of Iraqi democracy which
also occurred in Afghanistan is the
astronomical corruption
from looting in the streets to looting
the public treasury in a way that makes
saddam's gold-plated AK-47 look modest
but we'll talk about Iraq's current
problems in a future video the final
reflection is that George Bush did it
Iraq was indeed transformed into a
democracy but at a prohibitive price
many lives were lost along the way he
also had to throw a lot of money at the
problem because the United States spent
a huge amount of money on this war 800
billion dollars according to the most
conservative estimates and trillions of
dollars according to the other more
generous ones and so all that contrary
to what many people thought Baghdad ends
up being governed by the thing furthest
from what we couldn't consider a
Washington puppet
in a democracy the majority rules and in
Iraq the majority of the population is
Shiite therefore today the Shiite
factions that have received the most
support from Iran the great power of
Shiite Islam and today one of
Washington's greatest Arch enemies are
governing Iraq the biggest mistake of
the invasion was not having a plan for
the future of Iraq after the war
[Music]
Iraq is a democracy yes but it is now a
democracy under the influence of Iran
undoubtedly the biggest winner of the
Iraq war in the region the greatest
illustration that the U.S strategy has
not exactly been brilliant but hey now
it is your turn 20 years after the war
do you think it was a wise decision to
invade Iraq going back to Bush's words
was it worth the effort to transform
Iraq into a democracy leave us your
answers in the comments if you found the
video interesting please give it a like
and don't forget to subscribe to
visualpolitik all the best I'll see you
next time
[Music]